so
my name is marco rogers i work for for
yammer and this talk is about as he said
finding patterns in front and javascript
development
um
so we spent a lot of time talking about
javascript libraries and frameworks uh
you know which one to choose uh when to
use them when to write your own
which is hopefully never but um
unfortunately i'm not actually going to
give you answers to any of those
questions today
what i actually can do is give you a
peek into the way i think about front
end development today because there was
a point where i realized that
there are lots of shared patterns and if
we if we look at those shared patterns
it will give us better insights into the
landscape of how we build things today
so
see we can move forward a while back i
wrote this on twitter i tweet sometimes
um
uh and the question that i got back most
uh i had some people agree but the
question i got back most was what are
the patterns that you see like people
wanted to kind of discuss this
which i thought was great um so my goal
with this talk is to provide sort of a
mental model for pulling out these
patterns
being able to identify the core concepts
and being able to uh to kind of discuss
them across
different libraries and frameworks
this is going to be an incomplete list
because this stuff is still evolving and
because i don't know everything uh
unfortunately um but i think the best
outcome for me is when i get done with
this that you're like super annoyed that
i didn't get to go further into it and
that you want to continue the
conversation uh because i think that
that we need to so
uh
let's let's kind of talk about the three
main uh buckets that i put these into
the first um
is common patterns right so this is
these are kind of the core patterns that
people uh or at least in my mind the
core patterns that people are referring
to when they say nbc uh or mv star-ish
kind of thing right so we're going to
take a look at one of those um and uh
it's going to be kind of a baseline for
how what i mean by that these are these
are shared patterns across frameworks um
i'm going to dig into the advanced uh
some of the more advanced abstractions
on top of the mvc ish thing uh this one
this i think will be interesting for
illustrating what i think a lot of us
are doing today when we're trying to
build complex web apps whether we're
using a cohesive framework uh like like
ember angular or whether we're using our
kind of custom built thing that uh is
about five years old and which nobody
really wants to use anymore and yet um
it's still kind of hanging around um i
think you see the same patterns across
all of these things right and then
finally we'll look at some emerging
patterns these are ones that are less
common but i think are uh coming up more
and more frequently as we try to build
apps with with more sophisticated
capabilities
so
uh let's kind of jump right in to common
patterns uh and they they look like this
right so models views uh i want to be
pretty obvious i hopefully should be
pretty obvious to the folks in this room
um controllers the c is always kind of
nebulous but i think routers and
controllers are kind of kind of come
with that
and routing is probably the more
important feature for building single
page applications right being able to
route to a particular view
and then like restful api access because
obviously you need to get some some data
and shove it uh shove it into your ui um
i think these should be pretty familiar
to people uh we're gonna jump into one
of them so i can kind of illustrate what
i'm talking about
uh so let's talk about models right this
will be a rehash for folks
and it comes with these capabilities
generally
at least this is my contention this is
how i kind of outline this pattern in my
head
you get some objects that represent your
your data model right
you can inspect the properties on that
object you can read and write them uh
usually you can persist data to the
server because uh because that's handy
sometimes um and then uh the most
important part that i think makes this
into a pattern and not just kind of the
thing that we do with javascript all the
time is that
this model layer
is going to fire change events it's
going to tell you when these models have
changed
and allow you to register a callback so
that you can respond right and that
allows us to take this model layer
decouple it from the other parts of our
app whether it be our our views
templates uh what have you
but still be able to make it do do
interesting things right
so
uh does this make sense to people it's
not making sense rehash thanks
that's probably good um
so
let's take a look at how backbone does
this backbone should be familiar to most
people this looks pretty straightforward
you create a new backbone model right
give it some data id
this latest reply ad which is kind of a
date string you can inspect these
properties by pulling out the id and uh
comparing it to some other things and
angular
backbone wants you to use a getter for
this
um and then you can register a callback
right and in backbone it looks like this
it uses this nice uh kind of event
listener pattern that was popularized by
by jquery and node.js
depending on who you talk to
um
and so when latest reply at gets updated
this callback is going to fire and we
can we can do things
and then finally we can we can update
this model by calling this setter and
when we do that then our our callback's
gonna fire um this this isn't a surprise
to anybody right this is kind of what we
do is kind of the core of backbone uh
models
but
let's kind of compare it to what i work
with every day which is um you know the
the internal framework that yammer uses
which uh we call yamjs or sometimes
affectionately yam juice um and it looks
like this
let me let me go back
here's backbone
um
our framework looks like this
uh that slide did change they're very
similar but it did change and you can
kind of see that it's actually doing
exactly the exact same thing we're
creating an instance of this this thread
model giving it some data we can read
the data directly from the property
without using a getter um because that's
how our framework works but it amounts
to the same thing
then you've got this funky looking hook
thing uh where we're we're asking when
this thread has an update
register a listener right it's not as
nice as the the event listener pattern
that we we all know and love but it's
essentially doing the same thing right
it's allowing us to to listen for
changes
and then we want to
when we want to change this data we have
to go through this setter method called
update and instead of changing one
property we change multiple at a time by
passing a hash
and we need to use this setter so that
we can get our our event hooks um if i
have time i'll tell you a story about
that what happens when you don't use it
so um
this when i when i recognize that this
looks pretty similar to the other
frameworks that i was i was seeing this
is when this idea of pattern started to
develop in my head because anything that
you can do with this this core concept
and backbone you should be able to do
with our framework and you should be
able to do with other frameworks that
say they have a model layer for you
right
um but it doesn't always look this
similar and so i wanted to pull up a
different example that looked
looked a little bit different
so here's angular right
uh angular looks different and depending
on how you talk to it's like interesting
different or like annoying different but
it's different um but
the outcome is actually not that
different right it's doing the exact
same things instead of having this
object that you create you just use
plain javascript objects and you shove
them onto this special
scope object that angular gives you but
then you can read properties off of that
thing
um and you can set properties on that
thing you can see at the bottom there
and you set them directly just by by
updating properties like you do on
javascript objects
um but when it comes to that that last
that last thing that i said was really
important listening for changes
angular wants you to do that a little
bit different
when you shove it when you shove your
your model objects onto the scope
you can take advantage of this watch
function that they give you which says
anything that's attached to this scope
uh we're constantly checking for changes
and you can register for for for those
updates by by giving us this expression
right so i'm registering this watch
expression uh for latest reply ad and
it's going to do the exact same thing as
these other slides
right um
i when i first looked at angular i i
thought it was a kind of crazy town and
then
as i started to develop this pattern of
what a model layer was and i went back
to angular and i said how does angular
let me do this stuff that i know that i
should be able to do
then it started to make sense because i
started to know what i was looking for
in terms of
you know finding these capabilities and
so this example started to look a lot
like the other examples
which is good for me because i need
things that look similar i'm not that
smart so
um so now i can kind of do the things
that i know how to do with model layers
and in my framework and in backbone uh
and now and angular to a certain degree
and and each of these has has you know
further capabilities that they want to
to use to distinguish themselves and
some of them are really useful but at
the core these are the these are the
capabilities that you should be looking
for because if we go back
to what i outlined as my understanding
of a model pattern it's just these four
things these are the things that i'm
trying to do when you tell me that you
have models right
and i can do that in any framework that
i pick up today and if i can't
then that that's going to be an
indication that maybe it's not for me
right
if you know these core concepts you can
start to to uh have a better basis for
evaluating these frameworks
um is this making sense so far
um cool so
let's kind of jump into advanced
patterns i obviously won't be able to
hit everything today but i've got kind
of an example for each one of these
as apps get bigger and more complex
these core mvc patterns uh they start to
fall short right like they're not
cutting it as your app gets bigger as
you have to maintain more complexity you
want better abstractions on top of these
core patterns that allow you to to
manage that complexity
and this is where you get into to
advance patterns right
this is what advanced patterns look like
to me this is i think
kind of at the core of what i look for
when somebody says that they have a new
framework that i should check out right
nested views this is the idea that
you're going to take
what is
what the outcome is a big complex ui and
you want to break it down into something
that's more modular uh and and still
compose together such that you can kind
of treat it uh as a single entity um and
we'll look at that example so you see
what i mean
um complex rendering comes into into
play right it's very easy to take your
your one model and smash it into this
one template and like if that works out
it's great but sometimes you have to do
more things sometimes you have to
maintain the state of whether this item
was collapsed or closed and sometimes
you have to like format dates and
sometimes just to do these other things
that aren't just like kind of a straight
mashing of templates
and a framework should uh
hopefully help you do that stuff
model relationships this is the idea
that when you're when your
client-side app becomes more complex
you you want to take this model layer
that you're familiar with and start to
have better tools for representing your
entire data domain right so maybe you
have some messages and you need to know
which user sent them you want to be able
to take that message and say getuser and
it'll give you back this this particular
user
kind of uh automatically right so you
start creating these like has many
relationships and these belong to
relationships and essentially kind of
recreating your schema on the client
because it sounds like a like a really
awesome idea um and then later you might
regret it but in the meantime you're
like
you're like really jamming and and this
is the kind of thing that uh i consider
a really advanced pattern that when it's
working well it works really well
local data caching you know this is the
idea that you you've routed to a new
view and maybe it's one that that the
the user has seen before you've got all
the data for that view nothing has
changed but do you still have to make
another ajax call just in case right do
you know if something's changed or not
are you caching all that data locally so
that you can just reuse it right and it
allows you to do things like uh like
fast ui switching so uh local caching
and and two-way binding i think is um
is uh on everybody's minds today
and a lot of the big frameworks are are
pushing it
because it allows you to
make complicated updates to your ui
without writing a bunch of glue code
which is sometimes nice
um
so let's kind of dig into one of these
i like nested views it's it's the it's
the advanced pattern that i think needs
to go on top of every framework and if i
don't have it i'm really annoyed
um but first a quick refresher on on
what i mean by the kind of core view
pattern doesn't do much
render some markup to your dom right
respond to user input from your dom uh
and subsequently when things change uh
update your dom with with some things
right um pretty straightforward i hope
this is non-controversial
what we want to do is put a pattern on
top of that that says we're going to
allow you to take this core view and
compose them together to create more
complex structures right
and the nested view pattern kind of goes
like this so you can take these views
you can organize them to a parent child
tree right when you render at the root
of that tree
it's going to recursively render down
all of the children without you having
to do much work rather than you having
to go and touch every part of this ui
and create this object for your views
and pass and models and whatever
all that's done once by recursing down
the root of this tree
and and more importantly
but harder to define this tree has a
shared life cycle and what i mean by
that is
this rendering process you can reason
about you can say when i call render on
the root of this tree
either it's synchronous and when render
comes back all of my children are
rendered
or it's asynchronous and it's going to
say okay i'm going to return immediately
i'm recursing through this rendering and
when it's done i'm going to fire an
event let's say you've rendered some
things and then you know what the state
of this tree is right
and subsequently
when you're done with this tree you can
take that route and you can call destroy
or remove or dispose or whatever it is
you decided to name it
that week and uh it's going to recurse
and clean up for you right it's going to
go through those children take those
objects destroy them
unhook listeners there's all these
implementation details but you want that
thing to be um nicely able to be
reasoned about
otherwise you're going to have like huge
memory leaks
because you know that that happens to
some people that that i know who are not
me
so
um so you know this this idea of nested
views uh i think is really important
and i want to jump into it a little bit
so
i want to talk about yam juice first
this is actually an illustration of uh
of a yammer threaded conversation right
you get a you get a list of these in
your inner group feed
and so we want to render this thing
but we don't want to do it all at once
in one kind of huge module we want to
break these pieces down into things that
can be kind of reasoned about
independently so we've got the the
the first kind of threadstarter message
and it's called out it's more prominent
might have little attachments on it and
whatever else and then at the bottom
you've kind of got the list of replies
which are less prominent uh there's a
list of them you can tell who replied to
who and they've got a different look and
feel
and so we end up with three
uh primary views in order to render this
we've got our our kind of high level
thread list item we've got a thread
starter that encapsulates the starter
message and then we've got multiple
message uh message list items for our
replies and we want to be able to handle
this in a way that's nice
so
uh this is what it looks like in yam
juice uh it's not that nice um but it's
been working out for us right so you
create this threadless item
uh ask me later while it's called a
backbone component we're definitely in
the middle of
replacing some of these patterns with
standard backbone implementations
um so you create this threadless item
but inside this threadless item you're
going to do a couple of things you're
going to add your threadstarter as a
child view so you create your new
threadstarter and you prepend it to
this this threadless item and then
you're going to loop through all of your
message replies and you're going to turn
those into message list items and you're
going to append those also so these
views are have all been instantiated and
they're now all composed together
underneath this threadless item and then
all i have to do is create this
threadless item and call render and when
i'm done all this stuff's done looks
like that and it's great right
and i didn't have to go through a lot of
munching or whatever i just had to set
these up once create this uh parent
child relationship and this just happens
for me right not magically but in a way
that's like a nice abstraction okay
um
is this uh is this a thing that people
are generally familiar with or or have
seen in various places
um cool so when we look at other
frameworks
we can see it being similar in some ways
i chose marionette because i think it's
one of the more popular
advanced
pattern frameworks that are built on top
of backbone
which i think is cool
and
it allows you to do a very similar thing
for your message list items which is
your list of replies you're going to
create an item view and for your thread
list item which is your kind of um you
know encapsulating view you're going to
create a composite view because
marionette says if you create a
composite view we know that we're going
to render some children recursively and
it has that whole thing kind of built in
and you've got less boilerplate involved
you can just pass it you can say i'm
gonna i'm gonna do a message list item
uh underneath here and then you create
this thread list item and you give it
some collections and like boom like
things start happening right so you just
call render and you get the right thing
um
i i haven't i haven't used uh marionette
as much as i've used some of these other
frameworks um but as soon as i looked
into it i said i bet marionette does
this as soon as i looked into it i found
all the right elements to be able to
create the thing that i was trying to
create the thing that i knew that i
should be able to do uh if this is a
serious framework right so people are
having these same ideas right
independently of of each other because
these are this is a pattern that's kind
of emerging in people's minds and it's
and it's not a new thing right like this
is this is based on prior art like we we
know uh that these things are useful
when you're building complex uis and
we're just learning how what what are
the what are the right ways or what are
the most interesting ways to build them
and front in javascript right
so these these things look very similar
but i always want to kind of pull one
that looks less similar
and i wanted to mess around with uh with
image.js some more
and the amber.js
example looks like this
for this i decided to use custom
components
instead of nested views right um and
this is the thing where you know you can
kind of uh
stick these these kind of custom names
into your template and they're they're
an encapsulated version of the view that
knows how to render itself and has this
encapsulated behavior
but allows you to still kind of nest
things just like you do with with html
with normal html
and amber's tracking this
against the the web components standard
that's that's developing right now
so
uh within bar i kind of created this
this component called a message list
item uh for the internal one i left out
the thread starter but you know you kind
of get the drift and then your high
level thread list item template looks
like this so i'm making a thread list
item first thing i do is kind of stick
my thread starter in there and like
that's why that's all i really have to
do as long as it has access to the right
model for that thread starter it knows
how to render itself like this template
doesn't need to be bothered with the
details but they're now composed
together right and then i loop over my
replies and i do the same thing i create
message list items and i pass in each
reply and it knows how to render itself
and you should get something that ends
up looking somewhat similar to to the
threaded conversation that i had before
in yammer
in fact
when when yammer was evaluating new
frameworks uh this is basically the
exercise that i went through
i i
pulled every framework that i thought
might be interesting and i tried to
build a yammer feed with it right i
tried to see how far i can get applying
these same patterns that i've already
already used with uh with the internal
framework that we have and i'm like this
framework should allow me to do all
these things in a similar way or at
least one that i can reason about
and i got to varying degrees of success
based on based on the factors of uh the
opinionation of each framework um but it
was a really useful exercise and i
started to see these patterns emerge
um so the outcome here is very similar
right we get we get this kind of nested
view but the thing that i think is
really interesting here is that i think
a lot of people get thrown off because
this is template driven rather than
javascript driven
ember angular both i think prefer to be
template driven they kind of want you to
think about what your markup is and give
you hooks into it that allow you to kind
of hook into your your behavior
but i prefer the opposite right i prefer
to organize my javascript objects right
javascript code
that does what i want and then have
these templates kind of be a side effect
of of that that that kind of
orchestration going the way that i
wanted um but the outcome is the same
right like the nested view pattern i
think applies in both of these even
though they don't look anything alike uh
you can reason about reason about them
in similar ways right
um so uh if this is starting to kind of
sound repetitive like that's great
that's exactly what i wanted like i want
this stuff to look the same because i
think that's what we want and when we're
talking about these shared patterns is a
kind of
a way to look at these frameworks that
look very different and are really
trying to differentiate themselves and
say well if i have this this kind of
shared model in my head if i have this
mental model of how these things are
supposed to work because i know how the
front end works then i can use that as a
basis to understand
anything that these frameworks are
trying to trying to throw at me right
and that doesn't always work but it
definitely gives you a step ahead
so uh
let's kind of
round it out with some of the emerging
patterns
um these i think are the more
interesting ones uh and ones that i
think are um
harder to kind of find the patterns or
at least establish the patterns today um
but definitely worth looking at because
they're coming up more and more often
um they kind of look like this they're
less common they're coming up more and
more frequently
these patterns aren't built into every
framework yet although the the big major
ones are trying i know ember's doing
things and angular is doing things
around around making real time more
standard
and recognizing these patterns can help
you kind of uh look across the field and
see
um how these how different frameworks
are trying to solve these problems that
like i know some of you have today
and help you evaluate those right so
custom components we kind of looked at
with with ember but polymer and reactor
are doing uh are kind of at the
forefront of that i think um real-time
updates which we're going to talk about
uh people's go-to is usually stock at io
but uh there's definitely other other
things that you can grab like pusher
realtime sync which is related uh in
kind of a
you know save your models locally and
then have this always on syncing thing
going with your server
and then
also similarly related to that is kind
of going full on uh offline cache right
where your your model layer is persisted
locally at all times and then there's
this the syncing thing that that pushes
it to the server if and when it can um
but but offline access is kind of a
first-class citizen you know hoodie's
kind of leading the way
with that
and then finally device capabilities
because you want to kind of access
you know hardware capabilities on mobile
devices like your camera or geo location
when you look at this stuff
and you think you have had to do that
you've probably also gone through this
exercise where you're like well how the
hell i do that with framework x whatever
one you're using even if it's your
custom one and so people are kind of
gluing these together uh with you know
custom code that's hard to maintain and
so this is why i feel like there's a
pattern emerging here because lots of
people are doing it
but it's not a thing that you recognize
and the thing that looks the same or at
least i thought so right
so uh i want to look at real time
because uh everybody wants to be real
time these days and in fact i was i was
laughing because i noticed that the the
go-to app which was like the the to-do
app that people were using as a tutorial
for the framework has now switched to
the real-time chat uh tutorial right
so all these frameworks are trying to
differentiate themselves by having you
build something in real time because i
know that's what people are looking at
right
but when i looked around at this pattern
i was surprised to find a little bit
more consistency than i was expecting
for something that i thought was just an
emerging pattern
um
the way that people are integrating it
actually seemed very similar to me
but
as a pattern i also felt like there was
something missing so if you look at
these bullet points
obviously you can subscribe to real-time
updates from the server um but
the the thing that i think makes this a
pattern the thing that i think is really
useful here is the idea that those
real-time updates get dispatched through
your normal model layer in a way that's
very familiar to you and that you don't
have to spend a lot of time reasoning
about real time as separate from not
real time right we'll kind of see what
that looks like you can you can register
for uh for events just like normal
models
so
i looked at angular first
i didn't i didn't uh write these
examples i kind of googled around and
looking for what people were doing with
real time and angular and i found this
uh so this is kind of an example of of
how you might kind of build a blog that
gets real-time updates or whatever right
and so
you're kind of going into your angular
controller you've got your scope there
and you give it an empty list of items
that you're going to presumably fill
and you have this uh this initial method
to retrieve your initial data right so
just do a regular ajax call get your
items back and shove them on that scope
and you're good to get started right
but then
to add the real-time component they pull
in this service angular wants you to go
through these services to access data
and so they've got this this pusher uh
this pusher service that exposes the
subscribe method and he said subscribe
to you know whatever whatever collection
on the server will give you real-time
updates uh in this case just called
items and register a callback and every
time there's a real-time update of items
we're going to fire this thing and all
i'm doing doing here is pushing it onto
this this items array
and if you remember this is this is
there's not much else here because
angular is listening for changes to this
scope so all i have to do is push these
items here and all the stuff that's
listening for changes is going to update
and in this case they're going to update
in real time and sometimes that's really
all you need right like that's really
all you want is to say for this
particular list i wanted to update as
soon as these objects come in
as fast as possible um and that that's
all it takes in this case
um and i think that's pretty nice it's
very explicit which is uh which is cool
um but it's also kind of you know like
it could be better it could be
encapsulated a little bit better i don't
have to always worry about uh you know
setting up this subscribe and every
controller that i need this this
real-time stuff right
um so i jumped over to ember
googled around a little bit and i found
something extremely similar right
completely unrelated but extremely
similar this is from the discourse folks
uh who are heavy ember users
and uh they're doing a similar thing
building a blog want it to be real time
updates uh such and such and they do
kind of the same thing right so they're
in their controller
create the subscribe method that's gonna
give them real-time capabilities and
they're using this um this library
called a message bus which uh you know
if i'm not mistaken is a javascript
client that kind of connects to this
ruby back-end that gives you real-time
updates
and it just exposes the subscribe method
and it says subscribe to whatever thing
on your back end you want to get real
time from
uh you you know you register a callback
and we're it's going to give you data
and then you take that data and you you
shove it into the the part of the model
layer that you want to fire of its fire
update events
and then in the case of ember kind of
looks like this
the the controller model stuff and ember
is still a little sketchy to me but like
you don't need a lot to understand this
when you get some data here's where you
put it it's going to update in real time
no fuss no must right i put uh citations
for these these two uh that aren't mine
so you can go and check them out
so i was surprised that these things
look look pretty similar but you know
they're still pretty explicit they're
still not encapsulated well um and so uh
this i think is an interesting place to
look at uh yam juice again
we didn't talk about how yam juice
models are created but it kind of looks
like this you should define a new model
in this case we're making a feed which
is you know kind of that list of
threaded conversations and we're
associating it with a real-time feed
client uh appropriately named it's going
to say this is going to get real-time
data for you and surface it in a way
that you can use
and in a completely different file this
is a pretty sophisticated system which
means that it's uh it's kind of
overgrown and hard to maintain in a
completely different file you have your
base real-time client uh which has this
connect to real-time method and look
there's your subscribe right like it's
it's the same right like if you haven't
gotten the point yet this stuff is the
same so here's your subscribe you give
it an id and it's going to fire this
callback uh when your data is ready
uh but how does it surface that data
right that's where this is where the
difference comes in and this is where
this pattern is a little more complete
than the ones that we just looked at
because this is buried right this is an
abstraction
that's wrapped in our model layer so the
usage looks different the usage just
looks like this you just create your
your model like you like you do in any
other place and then you hook on to this
on thread update that says if there's if
there are new threads coming into this
this uh feed collection let me know
and that's it like you don't have to
mess around with the real time this
could be a regular ajax call this could
be real time we don't really care all of
our our ui is just hooked up to this
method that says if there's new stuff
i'm going to render it and so we're
we're uh you know encapsulated from
dealing with the real-time elements of
this and so those real-time elements
could change the implementation could
change right like our our real-time uh
requirements could change and none of
this stuff has to change right that's
that's ideally what you want from a
pattern is something that's actually
modular and encapsulated like this um so
i uh i hesitated to put this this like
these last slides in uh because i've
been doing these uh investigations of
these frameworks um but i wanted to look
at meteor um but i didn't i didn't get
very far uh because i think
something about meteor kind of twists my
brain in a way that is not very cool
so
um i only got so far with this but i i
did i did recognize that meteor i think
is establishing uh this real-time
pattern in a way uh that i think makes a
lot more sense right so this is the
meteor example in that you just create
you know this this meteor collection of
messages
right you do a query on it by saying
find and it's gonna it's gonna give you
back some initial data if you have it
cached locally but it's also going to
open a real-time connection or rather
the way that meteor works is that
there's always this real-time thinking
going on so
this query that you get is is always
going to fire these these changes that
you can observe
and you do that by calling observe
changes uh funnily enough
so you're gonna get uh updates when when
things are added or removed but this is
like a normal message collection that
you can then uh send into templates
right and instead of just you know you
loop over the messages that are there if
you look at you know this is our message
list you loop over the messages that are
there they're gonna get rendered but
also any any messages that get synced uh
subsequently from the server they're
gonna get rendered like this is all kind
of hooked up in a in a nice way
in a kind of magical way but it's also
kind of nice right
um and this is what i think we want the
the real-time connection to be is the
thing that where we go through our
models we use this pattern that we
already know the basic one that
everybody in here said yeah i already
know how to do that
but you get real time with the same
capabilities right so
uh i hope i've kind of illustrated uh
how these patterns have kind of helped
me evaluate these different frameworks
and i want to wrap up here
but i i like this quote this is from our
vp of engineering
um and when he said this i knew that he
had captured the the uh the core of why
i felt like this would be a good talk
because rather than kind of being
inundated by all these solutions that we
have to evaluate
it's much better to kind of get really
acquainted with the problem
right the thing that we're trying to do
and how we expect to be able to do it
and evaluate these frameworks against
that right rather than kind of saying uh
how do i do this in ember how do i do
this thing in angular
my question becomes i know i can do this
thing right like i want angular to
enable me to do this thing so i know
what i'm looking for right i'm looking
for my models i'm looking for uh how i
can inspect them i'm looking for how i
can uh register callbacks and i'm
looking for how i can nest views and i
know what to expect right that's been a
huge win for me uh in terms of doing
these evaluations right um and so uh
what i want to leave you with is like
let's find a way to talk more about
these shared patterns let's let's get
these examples let's like use github
let's get people to contribute let's
find out uh how far these patterns are
are spreading across our community uh
and use them as a context for for having
a stronger basis for front end
development
and that's uh that's basically it wish
we had more time for questions
so
you